nous sommes avec à gabriella bravo
journaliste correspondante basé à paris
spécialiste de l'amérique latine
bonsoir gabriel avance merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le brésil
donc pire deuxième pays le plus touché
par le cos vide derrière les etats unis
comment réagissent les brésiliens ces
chiffres qui donnent malheureusement le
tournis ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les brésiliens les discours des entre
les médecins et les scientifiques et les
discours du président james o na où il
ya une complète en cohérence entre elles
deux les précédents bolson araud a dit
que c'est un délit c'était une grippette
et il ne suit pas les conseils de la ms
comme le port de masques
la distanciation sociale aux as où même
et ses balades au milieu de la foule en
train de serrer des mains et embrasser
les gens donc les brésiliens ne font pas
confiance à son président c'est il ya
une enquête internationale qui le montre
une enquête menée par l'institut
allemand institut dahlia qui a interrogé
différents pays 53 pays
qu'est ce qu'ils pensaient sa population
de la gestion de son gouvernement et le
brésil pays où les gens croient moins à
son gouvernement
seulement 34 % de la population fait
confiance à la gestion de la pandémie de
jaillir molson a alors et pour cause
effectivement ghellab a beau
on devrait passer en termes de
contamination la vie à la barre du
million c'est énorme 45 mille décès et
dans le même temps on des confine
tranquillement il ya des commerces qui
rouvre ça paraît incroyable
vu d'ici où on a arrêté tout net
l'économie pendant deux mois oui parce
que le président jacques bolle sonar où
il ne vais pas à mettre en question
l'économie
en fait il a préfère sacrifier un peu sa
population puisque il a il a dit que de
toute façon tout le monde va mourir un
jour donc mais l'économie pour lui c'est
quelque chose de sacré et il n'avait pas
mais trop en danger l'économie parce que
il sait que si la population
si on rajoute à la crise sanitaire la
crise économique
ça peut provoquer des émeutes des
maîtres des la femme comment on a vu
dans d'autres pays de l'amérique latine
sauf que quand on voit les images voilà
des enterrements de masse et paraît même
qu'on enterrait voilà des corps sur la
plage de copacabana ça ça ne crée pas
des émeutes la population ne se révolte
pas avec ceux des propos qui peuvent
quand même choqué parce que voilà on va
tous mourir un jour où il ya le plus
tard possible et on imagine que les
brésiliens ne voit pas ce terrible bilan
d'un bon oeil quand même à nous non pas
du tout de toute façon les brésiliens
sont très méfiants en 200 gouvernement
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
population est fière et très polarisée
d'un côté il y à ces noyaux durs fidèles
au président angérien bolson avons fait
des conservateurs des personnes
religieuses surtout des évangélistes qui
vont suivre la parole du président coûte
que coûte ils vont le suivre et d'un
autre côté il y a une population qui se
sent complètement exclue du discours
politique exclut secours du pays une
population noire une population lgbt
les écologistes etc
ces populations ne fait pas partie du
discours même en partie des femmes qui
sont complètement est exclu du discours
du japonais naoki hier ouvertement
personnes aux forces existent macheist
donc cette gouvernement avait polarisé
encore plus à une situation qui
situation sociale qui couvait déjà au
brésil en plus rajouté à rajouter à ça
la crise sanitaire et la crise
économique ça peut être un cocktail
explosif
et pourtant le gouvernement dit la crise
est là mais elle est gérée est ce qu'il
y a tout même un petit peu de gestion de
la crise parce qu'on imagine que c'est
extrêmement compliqué dans les hôpitaux
par définition ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les voici vit un moment très
compliquée par rapport à son ministre de
la santé le ministre de la santé qui
sont maintenant c'est un ministre
intérimaire puisqu'elle les deux autres
ministres ont démissionné en moins de 30
jours et cette passion bonnart qui a mis
maintenant une personne issue des forces
armées c'est le seul général papa laze
way you et set général n'a aucune
expertise en matière sanitaire
il faut il faut aussi dire que pendant
six jours les chiffres des décès les
chiffres officiels du ministère de la
santé n'ont pas été donné et que c'est
la cour suprême fédérale qui a dû
contraint au ministère de la santé des
donner des chiffres plus simple à toute
la population alors dernière question le
chef indigène
pailla ken grands défenseurs de la forêt
amazonienne et est mort justement du
comique 19
cela rappelle justement durement que les
peuples autochtones sont loin d'être
épargnée par le virus qu'elle est le
retentissement parce que c'est quand
même un symbole est exactement ça a
provoqué une émotion un hiver un niveau
international
la moye la mort du classique et aga khan
et parce que c'est une personne qui a
mené un combat pour la forêt amazonienne
depuis des années depuis des années 80
qu'on est là
il a laminé un combat contre un barrage
qui voulait s'installer en amazonie et
après ça il a fait tout temps une
mouvance internationale pour la rallier
à sa cause de sauvegarder la forêt
amazonienne
néanmoins sa mort ce qui montre c'est
une met en lumière une situation de
précarité des communautés amérindiennes
à au brésil c'est les communautés
amérindiennes
ils sont tous des mentalités beaucoup
plus élevé qu'elle le reste de la
population le taux de mortalité cédant
9% contre 1 5% de la population
brésilienne donc à par l'émotion de la
mort du chef paille à cannes c'est aussi
une façon de mettre la lumière sur un
problème les problèmes de sam et indiens
d'une population qui n'est pas très
apprécié pour les présidents bernard on
remercie beaucoup aux débris à bravo
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france